it seems weird to me in your career
trajectory it seemed like such a fit for
you to have ended up on Saturday Night
Live like it would have been the vehicle
for you but I never make it in the
normal ways it's always the side window
or the basement window or something like
that same was you know it's been true
all the way along was was it a
tremendous defeat for you when you go in
audition for Saturday Night Live CU you
were on listen you a psychotic like
belief system that that goes uh you know
something magical is going to happen I
don't know how it's going to happen but
if if if there's no way in a new way
will be created kind of thing I can't
imagine them not accepting you on your
talent was so vast I mean crazy yeah
well they're they're making up for it
it's been it's been awesome and Lauren's
been amazing is it hard for you to do
Saturday Night Live in the sense that
everyone is expecting like Babe Ruth
you're going to hit it out of the park
I'm the funny Jim Carrey I've got I'm
the guy who does sketch comedy I got
discovered on In Living Color is the
pressure kind of enormous for you uh not
really really it just takes me back it
takes me you know performing in front of
the audience and stuff it's like a
little taste of what I used to get from
standup you know every time I do a talk
show or something it's or an award show
I'd usually go way too far because it's
my opportunity to be in front of a crowd
but that's what I like about you with a
award shows you go on and I know it's
never going to be boring you're going to
try I care about them at all so it's a
wonderful thing I mean it's nice when
people give you a nod it's always nice
when you go in and uh they they have
that famous Monday morning pitch meeting
and and you're the guest host do you go
in and suggest ideas to them or you just
sit I I I phone in a couple of weeks
before and say I want to do Matthew MCC
I want to do this I want to do that you
know the things that I kind of want to
nail so the Matthew MCC thing everyone
is talking about it when I'm done
rolling up this booger should I eat it
or throw it out the window it's a great
parody will you hear from someone like
that do you think he'll have a good
sense of humor about that kick my ass
you will he kick your ass it's always
that thought in the back of your mind
when you're rolling the booger see him
in that Dragon movie and go damn man
that guy can how long does it take you
to shoot that cuz it was a series of of
of commercials that was oh here's here's
the crazy thing okay so I start at 10:00
in the morning on Friday I do the
daytime shot then I go to Saturday Night
Live I rehearse I do uh uh costume
fittings I do you know meetings with
Lauren then I go back out on the road
and I'm out there till 5: in the morning
and then I go back to my hotel and get
like 4 hours sleep before I get up and
do the show ESS three times during
Saturday you mentioned you you you do a
live dress rehearsal and all that and
they they talk about when you do a
sketch in front of this live dress
rehearsal that the audience if it if it
bombs if a bit tanks they take it out
yeah did did something tank when you
were doing the do do they do they do you
try so and then can you go to La Michael
I try to make everything tank during the
dress rehearsal so so so so nothing gets
taken out and do you get upset when they
take something out uh well there's been
occasions you know I mean the seea thing
I was n really that nuts about doing in
the first place I was nuts about
getting you look nice too well when you
did that open leg thing I was like wow
he really talked well I was reallying
was fully dilated at that moment I'll be
honest when you spread your legs in that
costume I was like Jim's going to let
his balls fall out of that costume it's
just going to be my God I never thought
of that why Wen you
there